bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction sur tv fil 78 nous sommes le
29 avril parmi les sujets qui seront
développés au cours de la prochaine demi
heure la semaine de la mémoire de
l'esclavagé qui va s'ouvrir dans
quelques jours à saint quentin en
yvelines le programme les enjeux avec
mes sacs mapangou porte parole du
collectif en charge de l'organisation
les invités de cette édition apprenez à
créer votre propre jeu vidéo c'est la
promesse faite à guyancourt par l'espace
numérique auguste renoir le psg ce n'est
pas uniquement son équipe de ligue 1
c'est également une fondation qui depuis
1995 organise les journées d'action pour
les jeunes des quartiers défavorisés
exemple à plaisir ou 600 enfants de 6 à
12 ans se sont retrouvés autour du
ballon rond la prime versée aux communes
par le département des yvelines pour
inciter à la réalisation de logements
s'est terminée économies obligent le
contrat de développement de l'offre
résidentielle lancé en 2006 n'a pas été
relancée pour 2015 il permettait aux
villes de toucher entre cinq et dix
mille euros par logement réalisé
permettant ainsi le financement des
écoles ou encore des centres sportifs
alentours l'économie sera de 28 millions
d'euros par an en moyenne
et puisque l'on parle de construction la
fédération départementale du bâtiment
des yvelines s'est doté d'un nouveau
président pierre cojan entrepreneur en
maçonnerie succède à daniel taravella
dans un contexte très difficile d'après
elle les statistiques du ministère du
logement publiés ce matin le secteur du
bâtiment ne parvient pas à reprendre le
déséquilibre du rapport prix pouvoir
d'achat des ménages empêche l'activité
de décoller en france les mises en
chantier continue de reculer elles sont
en chute de 9% sur 12 mois et les
autorisations de construire sont en
repli de 7% avec l'invité de ce soir
nous allons parler de l' esclavage
semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé du
4 au 10 mai à saint quentin en yvelines
organisée par la septième fois par un
collectif dont le porte-parole est en
plateau bonsoir mes sacs matin goûts
sont avant de regarder la programmation
on va déjà à préciser votre démarche est
à la fois un moment de commémoration
mais c'est aussi un moment pédagogique
il est innocent d'enseignement aussi là
la mission de l'enseignement la
transmission de la mémoire donc des
actions avec des jeunes pour parler de
cette mémoire et transmet qu'histoire
le haut par le mal de cette question d'
esclavage on parle
pas mal mais pas super mais j'ai envie
oui on peut toujours un prépuce donc
c'est la mission que collective c'est
d'olmes d'aidé en fait à cette
communication d'un incident diffusion
d'informations le 10 mai de chaque année
marque en france la journée de
commémoration de la mémoire de la traite
négrière de l'esclavagé des noirs et de
ces abolitions un rendez vous qui n'a
été mis en place qu'en 2006 un décret
rien tabou a parlé un petit peu de cette
question
la preuve ce qui a eu le décret donc il
ya eu la vie facile et 2006 s'il vaut
mieux tard que jamais donc il ya eu la
loi de 2001 qui avait connu l'esclavagé
comme crime contre l'humanité et le
décret qui vient compléter cette loi qui
était prévu déjà par la loire qu'il
vient institué cette commune à la france
des propriétaires il faut noter que la
connotation ses frises et déjà c'est
dans les antilles les quatre
départements d'outre-mer il ya des dates
différentes qui correspondait en fait
aux dates de mise en oeuvre du le décret
la question de l'esclavagé nous sommes
allez vous poser la question pour vous
est-ce encore un sujet tabou en france
vos réponses
c'est important dont il sort n'ont pas
le temps il les a pas et c'est
maintenant on peut en parler librement
c'est plus du tout à vous je trouve
qu'on ne célèbre pas c'est contrairement
à d'autres souffrances mais après c'est
mon avis personnel mais je trouve qu'on
ne célèbre pas assez c'est pas qu'on me
dit la vérité mais on minimise
certains faits et on raconte pas tout
justement à l'école etc je pense qu'il
faudrait vrai plus en parler je pense
qu'elle est quand même pas mal de tabous
cacher derrière ça oui effectivement
c'est bien dommage parce que je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
là-dessus et peut-être pour faire
avancer les choses aussi non on en parle
on parle ici bien
éviter que ça recommence
on en parle beaucoup aux écoles c'est
bien déjà ça c'est bien au jeune classe
on a entendu un des jeunes dans ce micro
trottoir qui disait on nous dit pas tout
même des adultes qui disait on minimise
un petit peu
il est
très souvent mais globalement je pense
que on progresse on va dans le bon sens
puisque les programmes sont adaptées en
tout cas en voie de l'être et des écoles
primaires comment c'est déjà un pas mais
on en parle entre les gens n'en parlent
en seconde je pense que c'est mais on
peut toujours mieux faire j'espère que
ça va continuer et à partir du 4 mai il
ya cette série de manifestations vous
allez organiser on va regarder un peu
plus en détail le programme il a une
exposition tout d'abord panthéon de nos
héros mercredi 6 mai 17h c'est à la
casse qui est communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines attrape
qu'il y aura l'inauguration de cette
exposition
voulue cette année mettre en place c'est
une esprit sont en fait qui est appelé à
évoluer comme son nom l'indiqué c'est un
panthéon donc à chaque année on se
propose de chercher des héros connus ou
non connus et de faire des portraits et
cette année on a eu 15 aides dont
complaisant de porter de 15 pour mieux
connaître les pionniers effet que l'on
va inaugurer l'exposition en la
présentant aux élus aux associations et
un certain nombre de personnes on va
inviter à la casse du procès de raison
le 6 mai mais par la suite l'exposition
sera présentée à lille on se croit 6 pts
et les trois manifestations organisées
le vendredi le samedi et le dimanche ce
sera à la fois sur
montigny-le-bretonneux pour situer les
lieux puisque c'est à travers tout un
canton en yvelines toute façon il ya
votre site internet qui va s'afficher
aussi pour que les gens puissent s'y
retrouver programme très riche a encore
pour pour cette année de la de
manifestations vous organisé il ya un
autre rendez vous c'est à la médiathèque
jean rousselot il est question de
l'esclavagé à travers la littérature on
va écouter les grégoire martinez il est
assistant à la conservation du
patrimoine il nous présente cette
exposition c'est au micro d' elodie moi
c'est un sujet qui est pas évident à
traiter on sait qu'en 2006 quand elle a
été lancée c'est un moment fort enfin
d'une évocation christiane taubira qui
expliquait que par cette reconnaissance
était aussi la reconnaissance de
l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité je crois que la france était
un des premiers pays à le faire
peut-être aussi parce que là elle a
beaucoup occulté dans son histoire donc
je pense que le plus important c'est
surtout lancement pour apprendre à vivre
ensemble ces deux
à réussir à comprendre quelles sont les
raisons étaient les horreurs de notre
passé sur cette exposition elle est
montée en plus en mouvement il ya
d'abord effectivement les raf donc tout
ce qui s'est passé en afrique avant le
commerce triangulaire après il ya le
voyage entre guillemets voilà entre
l'afrique et les colonies françaises et
après il ya le principe de résistance
avec les neg marrons voilà les façon de
s'organiser pour recouvrer leurs livres
et leurs libertés
exposition dans le cadre donc de la
semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé à
saint quentin sur le site jean rousselot
à guyancourt et on se penche aussi sur
l'après abolition parce qu'il a fallu
continuer à se battre après on parle de
l' esclavage mais tout ne s'est pas
arrêté du jour au lendemain il ya eu la
reconnaissance des droits aussi après
qui vendra la fin à dix ont encore un
peu en 1848 et la famille continue et
bisons là
le combat ou en toile de travail pour
aider les stars et leurs descendants à
se libérer on va dire si le plan mental
tant que ya eu dans cette exposition la
jungle où il ya l'aspect vie et les
écrivains qui ont vidé un fait assez
pâle à tout pour tous ceux qui ont
travaillé si la multitude vous permettre
à ceux qui ont vécu cet événement de
retrouver un peu de fierté et de pouvoir
19 et le 30 semaines d'ailleurs à la
médiathèque l'agent rousseau il y aura
une journée avec des lectures des textes
autour de de rosa parks
1955 elle avait vous vous en souvenez
bien évidemment refusé de céder sa place
un blanc dans un bus puisque c'était
tout simplement interdit pour les noirs
de s'installer dans les bus à cette
époque là on justement ça nous amène
peut-être une parenthèse liée à
l'actualité la suite aux obsèques je
vais resituer la situation de freddy gré
jeunes afro-américains mort à 25 ans
lors de sa garde à vue le 19 avril à
baltimore aux états unis a été le
théâtre est encore le théâtre de
violences qui ont conduit les autorités
du marineland a décrété l'état d'urgence
les émeutiers certains dans le calme
dénonce racisme et violences policières
vous dites que lorsque vous voyez ces
images là par exemple que l'histoire se
répète peut rappeler qu'en 1968
également à baltimore il y avait eu des
émeutes après l'assassinât du pasteur
martin luther king
l'histoire
servier comme rudy p ça justifie encore
plus s'il fallait le justifier ce genre
d'action pour que disons le désirent
puissent pas se reproduire et
pas à me les héros on traite dans
d'autres expositions
il sera aussi d'ailleurs pour la
question de cette projection de selma en
ouverture de la semaine selma qui
retrace la lutte de martin luther king
qu'on évoquait il ya un instant c'est à
la salle jacques brel à montigny le
bretonneux le cinéma comme la
littérature qui retrace l'histoire de
l'exclavage c'est l'objet d'une
exposition vous proposez là aussi cette
exposition ce rendez vous autour du
cinéma votre les supports culturels sont
importants exactement vous d'essayer de
prouver dès les différents canaux par
lesquels
ils ont un thème du public il ya des
gens qui préfèrent plutôt du cinéma
rappelé
que la qualité du livre donc on a ici on
a travaillé en fait sur les deux
expositions donc l'expression
littérature qui prend l'histoire mais
qui illustre pas des livres qu'on trouve
évidemment dans les médiathèques mais on
fait aussi le même le même exercice un
proposant un l'illustration parle
différents films donc ça ça sert un an
l'encours sinestro pour le signer 7
c'est le mercredi 6 mai on a parlé de la
littérature on va parler du cinéma comme
vecteur autour de cette communication
vous mettez en place pour pour la
mémoire autour de l'esclavagé et puis il
ya aussi le sport oui les sports c'est
peut-être là aussi
les et du noma où on va trouver plus de
monde parce que six blessés par
excellence et cette année on a voulu en
fait de rendre encore plus démocratique
est-ce que les années passées c'était
plus de vrais sportifs puisqu'on on
centre et aussi le basket à cette nuit
on a un
initier des randonnées ou des familles
pourront qu à ceux pour meunier on est à
51 il ya beaucoup d' espaces verts donc
on pourra se promener en 2h03 est aussi
l'époux se retrouver ensuite ah oui
j'aime d'alain colas pour un déjeuner
champêtre tout ce qui peut pas marcher
sont aussi invités au déjeuner champêtre
c'est à montigny-le-bretonneux vendredi
8 mai journée sportive commémoration
qu'un être les sportifs et leurs
familles comme vous venez de de
l'évoquer vous utilisez donc ces
différents moyens est-ce que vous avez
se verront support vecteur est ce que
vous avez le sentiment là c'est la
septième année
et ça nous ramène une fois de plus à
l'actualité aux états unis par exemple
que la situation
s'améliore pas vraiment au fait qu'on
on répète toujours toujours la même
chose et que malgré tout ça ne progresse
pas
disons que les fournisseurs non
sentiment que je devais
sa progression à l'égard de micro
trottoir il ya deux ans je pense qu'on
voit de plus en plus des gens qui ne se
sentent pas jeudi vers 10 par un parmi
les demandes donc je vais pas dire que
ça progresse mais il ya un produit
beaucoup de chemin à faire et de toute
façon je dirais
si on ne peut pas se séparer quelque
chose qui va s'arrêter donc on doit
contenir perpétuellement a comme moi et
je crois que c'est le summum de
commémoration de toutes les communes
nation c'est pourquoi n'oublie pas mais
quand on va aussi même un peu plus loin
dans l'actualité mais pas si bon que ça
il ya quelques semaines quelques mois
les attaques qui ont été faites contre
la ministre tombe bien qu'ils avaient
fait main donc c'est ce que je disais
donc le sens de l'économie de ces propos
du déjeuner mais aussi le moins jeunes
puissent se souvenir de l'histoire il
n'est pas comme est en tout cas mais pas
celui ci la nuit à la facilité merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau porte parole
du collectif pour la semaine de la
mémoire de l'esclavagé à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines semaine qui va
débuter le 4 mai il aura des événements
pendant sept jours et il y aura
également la commémoration le 10 mai
jour nationales merci une fois de plus
la suite du journal c'est avec la 12e
prairial une manifestation qui se
déroule fin avril à montigny le
bretonneux autour des fleurs et des
jardins et qui permet surtout de dégager
des fonds pour lutter contre la cécité
le lion's-club des trois villages pilote
toujours cette opération mais quel
ennemi d'euros et yolaine torres pour ce
sujet
l'après rial une véritable tradition à
montigny le bretonneux pour la douzième
année consécutive lyon ce club de
montigny les trois villages à organiser
cet événement dans la ferme du mal et
l'art floral les équipements de jardin
et les produits du terroir étaient une
nouvelle fois à l'honneur nous
accueillons environ 50 exposants sur la
thématique de marché de plantes et de
fleurs
avec bien sûr quelques autres six ans
qui sont les artisans de bouche et des
artisans d'art c'est le rituel chaque
année on vient on est présent et on
assure qu'il pleuve ou qu'il fasse très
beau on vient quoi qu'il arrive une
manifestation pour la bonne cause cette
année encore l'intégralité des bénéfices
réalisés pour le week-end sera reversée
au profit de l'association des chiens
guides de paris une structure qui aide
les aveugles et malvoyants dans leurs
déplacements depuis de nombreuses années
nous consacrons les bénéfices les
l'argent récolté de la part de cette
action vers cette association là qui
donc forme et entretiennent les
différents chiens qui viennent un an à
l'aide de des personnes souffrantes si
c'était au total 6000 de son auront été
collectées pendant la manifestation une
somme qui permettra de financer un tiers
de la valeur d'un chien pour aveugles et
malvoyantes un chien c'est un peu près
25 mai d'euros pour faire attention
quand on dit ça ce sont des chiffres qui
peuvent un peu inquiété mais on prend
bien l'intégralité de la vie et du
parcours du chien avec des événements
comme celui-ci c'est que l'on va donc
nous aider financièrement avec une
quote-part 2e ce qui aura pu être
récoltés aujourd'hui nous c'est assez
important pour nous un partenariat qui
sera reconduit l'année prochaine la 13e
édition de l'après rial et déjà
programmée pour avril 2016
santé avec une nouvelle implantation du
coeur artificiel développé par la
société car matt depuis à ses locaux des
yvelines un troisième patient a été
opéré à l'hôpital européen georges
pompidou le 8 avril c'est un test
important dans la poursuite de l'essai
de faisabilité meuse est menée par la
pme parmi les critères de succès la
survie à 30 jours après l'implantation
et la récupération fonctionnelle des
organes vitaux de son côté l'association
saint-quentinoise médias handicap a fêté
ses 11 ans le week-end dernier présent
pour l'événement qui se déroulait à
l'hôtel le méridien à paris des élus
locaux le défenseur des droits personnes
handicapées où encore des personnalités
michel leeb geneviève de fontenay
lucienne mauro masi handicap se bat pour
la reconnaissance dans les médias des
personnes en situation de handicap il
souhaite contribuer à leur faciliter
l'accès aux métiers de la communication
et de la culture
loisirs avec les vacances qui se
poursuivent et cette fois ci c'est le
jeu vidéo qui est à l'honneur un secteur
qui se porte bien près de 70 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires annuel est une
tendance qui se développe celle de créer
soi même son propre jeu souvent de
manière minimaliste en atelier pour
guider les jeunes créateurs se tient à
guyancourt à l'espace public numérique
auguste renoir
les yeux rivés sur l'écran ils jouent
aux jeux vidéo à raison de deux heures
par jour mais pour une fois pas
d'interdiction c'est dans le cadre d'un
atelier proposé pendant les vacances par
l'espace public numérique car ici on ne
fait pas que jouer on s'initie surtout à
la programmation visuelle leur jeu c'est
eux qu'il crée mais une interface
graphique qui nous permet de pouvoir
donc de créer les jeunes vont pouvoir
créer leur environnement les montagnes
les personnages les programmes et pour
qu'ils avancent pour qui saute mais de
l'eau pas mettre de l'eau faire la nuit
il ya plein vraiment un environnement
très très vague et variés ils gèrent
leurs scénarios voilà donc après il y en
a qui vont faire des jeux coopérative de
déjà un peu plus d'opposition avec des
adversaires au ses propres à morgan à 14
ans et si elle participe c'est justement
pour développer sa créativité
le fait de pouvoir vraiment créer ce
qu'on veut
c'est vraiment sympa et chacun peut
faire des choses différentes et moi j'ai
créé un monde où on peut faire un jeu de
course avec des décors et des niveaux
des niveaux plus plus de mon dieu j'ai
écrit un petit caux du qui nous placer
dans un labyrinthe pour aller toucher
une grande étoile pour gagner de jeu
c'est tout
c'est un petit jeu sympa pour tester
comment faire un jeu tranquille on
pourra apprendre à faire ça mon petit
frère
car tout l'intérêt c'est qu'ils peuvent
ensuite mettre leur jeu sur pc ou xbox
apprendre en s'amusant un atelier
ludique mais pas seulement l'objectif
faire découvrir les métiers du numérique
et des métiers d'avenir malentendu
l'atelier s'est terminé ce mercredi
cette jeune client courtois y ont
participé
il sera reconduit au mois de juillet
toujours autour de ses vacances
scolaires la fondation psg était lundi à
plaisir suite un partenariat signé en 95
avec le conseil départemental des
yvelines organise régulièrement des
journées d'action 600 jeunes de 6 à 12
ans issus des quartiers défavorisés
peuvent ainsi participer à des
animations ludiques éducatives autour du
football bien évidemment michael almy
drouot william l
il dribble passes et tirs au but
aujourd'hui jouent tous sous le même
maillot en partenariat avec le conseil
départemental la fondation psg était
tira plaisir pour une journée autour du
football la fondation paris saint
germain c'est le versant un petit peu
social du club du paris saint germain
l'objectif c'est de proposer justement à
ces enfants qui n'ont pas la chance de
partir en vacances des activités sur une
journée donc l'idée c'est de rassembler
une centaine donc un maximum
pour leur faire participer à l'univers à
la fois du paris saint germain mais
aussi à travers cette journée de leur
transmettre des valeurs éducatives et
sportives au total aujourd'hui 86
enfants de 6 à 12 ans ont participé à
l'événement les jeunes issus du club de
foot et de différents centres de loisirs
de la ville ont été encadrés par les
éducateurs de la fondation au programme
entraînements et matchs comme les pros
du multi ford et des exercices de foot
et après un tournoi tout et après
récompense
le matin et les retours net bac c'était
parce que c'est
bon j'ai de decker quoi
par lé ballon le ballon c'est ce qui la
rue aujourd'hui mais c'est aussi le
cadeau qui les attendaient à la fin
souvenir de cette belle journée et
lorsqu'on leur demande quelle est leur
joueur préféré la réponse est unanime
ibrahimovic on brave on est vraiment
vite chaud si j'atteins ibrahimovic
aujourd'hui la fondation se déplacer à
voisins elle sera au mieux demain et
caméras jeudi à rambouillet au total
dans les yvelines ce sont près 600
enfants qui profiteront des fuites
dispositif pendant les vacances
culture à présent est le cycle de
conférences d'histoire de l'art à
montigny le bretonneux rencontre avec
l'une des conférencières qui le 5 mai
évoquera au conservatoire des arts
l'exposition velasquez et les siens
présentée actuellement grand palais à
paris
à la manière d'obélix claire de la
varenne est tombé dedans petit ce qui
l'animait la fait vivre c'est sa passion
pour l'art un parcours artistique
plurielle et diversifiée a conduit cet
ancien élève de l'école du louvre à
devenir peintre restauratrice de
tableaux et conférencière en art lors de
ses conférences accompagné de
projections clair ne cherche pas à nous
raconter l'histoire mais à nous donner à
voir je ne me contente pas de parler de
la biographie du peintre de
l'iconographie du tableau bien sûr je
faire minimum mais comme je peins je
vois la facture je vois le style un
tableau c'est pas seulement ce qui
représente ou l'histoire de la vue du
pâtre sait vraiment comment il est un
son style sa facture les touches de
pinceau les rapports de couleurs
d'ombrés et de lumières c'est tout ça
qui fait qu'un peintre un style
particulier et pour faire comprendre au
mieux le style dans un tableau clair
prend toujours pour exemple la façon de
peindre les portraits de celui que l'on
surnomme le peintre des peintres
velasquez quand il peint comme ça un
oeil le nez enfin une partie du visage
il va pas faire tous les poils des
sourds si le creux de la paupière il va
pas dire une masse sombre qui va prendre
dans l'ombre aussi bien une partie de
l'irie de la paupière du sourcil et de
l'ombre du nez et des cons ce recul tout
est là il ya même la personnalité la
force là la psychologie du visage et ça
c'est époustouflant lors de sa
conférence claire propose en a parmi ces
projections le portrait du pape innocent
10 de vélasquez exposées actuellement au
grand palais non sans malice un portrait
considéré par certains comme le plus
beau portrait du monde savait que ce
tableau
le pape avait dit trop pauvre héros trop
vrai et ce qui est extraordinaire à
l'exposition c'est que ce panneau
d'innocents 10 ce tableau est sur un
panneau et de l'autre côté du panneau il
ya une copie on voit la copie et on
comprend tout c'est un tableau qui qui
peut frapper tout le monde à condition
qu'on montre aussi comment c'est pas
parce que sinon j'ai peur que des gens
passent en disant
un pape on s'en fiche quoi mais un pape
pimparé l'espèce pour découvrir d'autres
anecdotes sur velasquez et les
subtilités de sa facture rendez vous
mardi 5 mai au conservatoire des arts de
montigny
le 10 juin vous le découvrirez dans une
nouvelle super production américaine le
trappistes omar sy sera à l'affiché du
remake de jurassic parc jurassique world
mais le comédien lui est déjà en train
de préparer la suite de sa carrière
outre atlantique
regardez cette photo de lui publié sur
twitter par le réalisateur ron howard
ils sont actuellement en train de
tourner a venise les premiers plans de
la suite du da vinci code baptisé
inferno toujours avec tom hanks sortie
prévue cette fois ci en octobre 2016
merci d'avoir suivi cette édition je
vous retrouve demain même heure pour un
nouveau point sur l'actualité locale
excellente soirée sur téléphiles tout de
suite kiosques le magazine de la culture
présenté préparé par catherine mulato
excellente soirée